vielen lieben Dank für Eure Kommentare
und der möchte ich auch gleich mit
loslegen denn John Peters hat
geschrieben danke für die tolle
Reportage fand es einen spannenden
Einblick in die Klimakonferenz mit
passender und persönlicher Note wie es
im reformat üblich ist mein Respekt auch
an die Ärztin so viel Selbstvertrauen
muss man auch zuerst mal aufbringen um
einen John Kerry bei seinem
Mittagsschlaf zu konfrontieren ehrlich
gesagt das ging mir ähnlich wir standen
da er lief um uns herum und wer meinte
immer noch so wir müssen daran wir
müssen jetzt an ihn ran also wenn nicht
Du dann ich also ich gehe da jetzt hin
dann ist sie einfach straight auf ihn
zugegangen weil sie dann gemerkt hat
okay jetzt ist noch der Moment wo sie an
den Bodyguard vorbei sozusagen zu ihm
kommen kann und das zeigt aber auch das
auf so einer Klimakonferenz so etwas
möglich ist das eine Ärztin wie Bea an
einem John Kerry herankommen kann das
geht ja eigentlich nur dort für sie hat
es sich zudem noch gelohnt das hat sie
mir gesagt weil so viel Aufmerksamkeit
hätte sie nirgendwo anders bekommen denn
im The Guardian zum Beispiel war sie
direkt auf einer Zeile genannt als Joe
Biden der amerikanische Präsident dort
war und Ärzte protestieren gegen den
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel Nora Regelin
hat geschrieben wow super aufbereitet
und sehr toller Journalist i like weiter
so ja vielen vielen Dank das ist sehr
lieb und ich muss natürlich auch sagen
es gab ja auch also mein Fazit ist ja
relativ negativ dort und ich muss aber
auch sagen es gab auch gutes also besser
gesagt meine
Protagonisten wie Marie Claire Graf oder
Klaus Ammann mein Radio Kollege die
haben mir auch ein zwei gute Sachen
genannt die dort passiert sind auf
dieser Klimakonferenz wo ist sich
vielleicht doch für diejenigen die daran
dann gelohnt hat eben da zu sein eins
ist ja wie wir wissen die armen Länder
und für die wurde jetzt ein vor
eingerichtet für Klima bedingte Schäden
und das ist wirklich ein tolles Ergebnis
das sagt auch Maria klar
wir haben sehr wohlere Länder für die
sogenannte lost
Verhandlungen
[Gelächter]
jetzt momentan
noch keine verbindliche Regulierung
hat mich darauf hingewiesen dass auf den
Nebenveranstaltungen von den
Verhandlungen also auf dieser Messe
Klima Messe da waren ja auch ganz viele
Aussteller und dort hat er sich umgehört
und auch was positives gefunden es gab
rund um Verhandlungen die ganzen Hof
verst
Deal sein können machen
[Musik]
im Kampf gegen Klimawandeln Pipo
Langstrumpf hat geschrieben als ob so
ein Ausflug irgendetwas ändern würde
also jetzt ist ja die Frage mein Ausflug
also ich als Person der darüber fliegt
oder die über 40.000 geflossen sind ich
kann jetzt nur für mich sprechen
sozusagen wenn ich sage ich als
Journalist der dahin geflogen ist
der konnte ja schon ein bisschen etwas
für jeden Verändern der dann meine
Reportage sehen konnte also ein bisschen
den Blick hinter die Kulissen dort wie
funktioniert eine Klimakonferenz was
passiert da wer ist dort wie sieht das
aus sonst hören wir in den Nachrichten
oder sehen in den Nachrichten eigentlich
immer nur dieses eine Bild da sitzen
zwei drei Leute dann spricht jemand
davor und erzählt etwas wir kriegen
eigentlich nicht mit was dort passiert
und das wollte ich eigentlich
rüberbringen ein anderer Freund von mir
hat auch gesagt hey man muss doch nicht
immer auf diese Klimakonferenz drauf
hauen die ist doch so wichtig und da der
recht also Frau sommerroger hat mir das
auch zweimal im Interview gesagt das ist
diese Klimakonferenzen braucht nein
nicht es ist nicht der einzige Ort
weltweit wo alle Staaten
dem Thema zugewendet wenn die Klima
kommt mit mir überhaupt
in der Reportage war natürlich schade
als Ferienparadies und dieser Kontrast
und alles das war natürlich mein Fokus
und daher habe ich natürlich ein
negatives Fazit gezogen zum Schluss weil
eben dort vieles nicht nachhaltig ist
und irgendwie das Gefühl und der Drive
nicht aufkam was ich bemerkt habe aber
hey es gibt immer noch weitere
Klimakonferenzen und die finden an
vielen anderen Orten statt und es
braucht sie einfach in Zukunft dass wir
alle miteinander das Thema Klimawandel
und Klimakrise besprechen wie man das
angeht denn alleine ist anzugehen bringt
nichts aber was ich auch immer wieder
gehört habe es bringt auch nichts hier
große Versprechung zu machen denn in
jedem Land muss jedes Land dafür einzeln
einstehen den Klimawandel zu bekämpfen
und da in Aktion treten dass du jetzt
nicht eine Klimakonferenz sondern dass
du das Land und die Menschen in dem Land
sich das PS Monster schreibt eine
Konferenz mit Hauptsponsor Coca-Cola und
die vorbildliche Schweizer die trample
mit dem Velo was wohl extra angefertigt
und eingeflogen wurde 4 km weit aber ey
lieber eine SMS doch schauen als gar
keine Tiere ehrlich es ist keine Satire
es wäre mir auch lieber als wäre eine
Satire in mancher Hinsicht denn ich
wünsche mir doch auch eher so ein gutes
Ergebnis zum Schluss wo dann die Länder
sagen wir einigen uns verbindlich darauf
dass wir etwas ändern und dass wir ein
Zeichen setzen ein Signal und wir gehen
nach vorne aber nein das ist hier leider
nicht passiert auf der Seite des 1,5° C
muss man sagen und ich finde es
eigentlich gut wenn man dann wenigstens
mit dem Velo zur Klimakonferenz fahren
kann und so ein kleines Zeichen setzt
das fand ich schon recht Smart immerhin
das Bild hat sich vielleicht auch ein
bisschen in die Welt rausgetragen eine
Fahrradtour mitten auf der Autobahn wir
sind insgesamt 8 Spur Autos und eine für
Fahrräder nur die Fahrradspur wird
eigentlich nicht benutzt außer von
Schweizern Holländern und ein paar den
habe ich gehört und ja
wer weiß ob es nach der Konferenz
überhaupt noch eine Fahrradspur hier
braucht weil alle sind hier mit dem Auto
unter dem Bus unterwegs
hat geschrieben ganz ehrlich ich habe
jahrelang in charmische gelebt und wir
haben Eigentum dort und dementsprechend
ist sie noch viel dort vor Ort aber die
Fahrradstreifen sehe ich zum ersten Mal
ich würde persönlich dort auch nie Velo
fahren viel zu gefährlich ja also
ehrlich das hatte ich gedacht es kam mir
so absurd vor dass da überhaupt ein
Fahrradstreifen ist und ich bin davon
ausgegangen dass es da vorher keinen gab
und ich gehe auch davon aus dass der
vielleicht irgendwann wieder
zurückgebaut wird denn wozu ein
Fahrradstreifen wenn keine Fahrräder
aber ja es war eine spannende Erfahrung
in Scharmbeck ich hoffe ich konnte euch
ein bisschen Einblick in die
Klimakonferenz geben so dass ihr
erfahren habt was dort abgeht wer dort
ist und das starke Frauen wie Bär
albermann und Marie kläre Graf und ein
schäferhändler Franz perede extrem
schnell unterwegs ist dort sind und die
alle so motiviert und engagiert dabei
sind das gibt mir doch ein relativ gutes
Gefühl dass ich weiß da sind Menschen
die engagieren sich die sind dabei die
gehen nach vorne und das es könnte sein
dass die dann auch den Unterschied
machen dass etwas passiert